dans le prix de l'essence il ya presque
autant de textes que de pétrole ces
taxes servent à financer les
infrastructures routières il transports
en commun mais plusieurs estiment que
cette formule a fait son temps qu'il est
temps de taxer les automobilistes n'ont
pas au plein d'essence
mais au prix le mètre parcouru un
changement qui pourrait survenir d'ici
cinq ans estime la chambre de commerce
du montréal métropolitain
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on voyait
venir en théorie mais là ça approche à
grands pas en pratique et c'est le fait
que les voitures électriques des gens
dans des voitures hybrides mais les
voitures électriques vont se multiplier
et donc il ya beaucoup d'usagers de la
route de propriétaires de véhicules qui
seraient exemptés évidemment du poids de
la taxe sur le carburant des
technologies gps permet de suivre un
véhicule à l'adresse ce que font déjà
certains assureurs
il suffirait d'envoyer une facture à la
fin du mois une taxe kilométrique elle
pourrait être modulée selon où on est
est-ce qu'on est en campagne nous ont
fait beaucoup de kilomètres et donc
peut-être qu'elle pourrait être plus
faible au kilomètre est ce qu'on
voudrait diminuer l'impact sur la
congestion en l'arrosant sur terre
certaines zones si on fait du
kilométrage à ces horloges ont demandé
au véhicule les cris de payer leur juste
part pour une session la route très
intéressant de regarder pour diminuer
les souffrances on contourne la
fédération canadienne des contribuables
a lancé une pétition contre
l'éventualité d'une telle taxe
on y voit d'abord et avant tout une
attaque est la vie privée les québécois
pour pouvoir avoir une telle taxe
faudrait une base de données qui suivent
l'ensemble des déplacements les
québécois on a vu on a vu avec revenu
québec desjardins cape town c'est écrit
c'est le calme à deux années qu'on prend
des risques énormes
le texte sur l'essence rapporte 2,8
milliards au québec et du ministère des
transports estime qu avec
l'électrification des transports
la taxe sur l'essence produira de moins
en moins de revenus le gouvernement dans
sa politique énergétique vise à réduire
de 40 % la vente de produits pétroliers
d'ici 2030
donc grosso modo ça veut dire réduire de
40% les taxes perçues sur les carburants
la taxe kilométrique devrait remplacer
la taxe sur les carburants mais
plusieurs craignent qu'elle ne fasse que
s'ajouter ici monsieur marsolais radio
canada montréal